hello reject nation Greg Alba here John
honest trailers for one of my favorite
movies of the year thus far probably in
my top 10 by the end of the year oh yeah
Black Panther people hmm I'm excited to
see what they say I'm excited to see
what they have to say before we do that
patron of the day shout out for Diego
Shai Dez this good-looking sob is
graduating high school and might have
already graduated at this point actually
I forget how high school years worked
anyway Diego I hope you go off to a good
college
I hear it's not a waste of money or time
I hear everyone who gets a degree lands
a really good job so you have a great
career ahead of you don't injure
yourself during all the jujitsu you do
and also congratulations on landing a
hot-ass girlfriend I could care less
about her personality what matters is
she's hot and that's all that counts am
I allowed to say she's hot I think
they're both 18 you know why don't why
not just chance it because you know
they're states where the legal age of 17
call me by your name anyway Diego we
love you and can't wait to talk with you
on a Google hangout again this weekend
buddy mwah let's watch this honest
trailer for black panther
hooray
John Bailey hey doing John Mayer
watching after 17 movies the MCU finally
went black put a black Cruz like a
superhero movie that's one of the best
ever released leaving its heaters with
only one option watching every other MCU
movie ever made black panther just when
you thought chadwick boseman had called
dibs on every black I got the high tech
suit of the all-natural steroids of
Captain America and the invisible jet of
Wonder Woman but one thing sets him
apart from all the other MCU heroes not
because he's black not because he's
royalty no it's just this Marvel hero
just won't quit the Deep Freeze internal
in headlights are you finished
well his dad is man it didn't crack a
joke I thought you had to be a smartass
- safe journey to a car - a combination
of the Jetsons in a 1990s Jet magazine
the source of all the world's vibranium
a material so powerful it tubs Tony
Stark's tech and dr. Strange's magic as
the BS that can do whatever the script
brings cool them this secret Kingdom has
been hidden for centuries thanks to an
ironclad policy of asking people not to
say anything but the slave trade brutal
dictators two world wars multiple alien
invasion using stolen vibranium to
destroy the earth they're finally ready
to get involved
Bay Area will stay hidden steps you guys
after taking 18 movies to get six
quality villains but for that shining
moment we had call Andy circuses joyce
betrayal of a guy who doesn't have to
wear a mocap suit michael be my favorite
too Jordan of marble villains
hey aunty he's the buffest I graduate
from MIT who's ribbed for your pleasure
Ted who actually wins the moral argument
and changes the hero's mind or Wakanda
[Music]
so wait killer was right I have not used
to this much nuance in my marble
building while the boys are in play it's
the women of Black Panthers yeah word
like a coy a literal snatcher of wigs
hahahaha expert in weaponized beans
Angela Bassett as herself and Nakia who
after all the debate between T'Challa
and kill monger was making the same case
all along and never got the credit for
it
akanda is strong enough to help others
in critical self seem awesome to say the
Royal Family
oh so she saved the future of the Black
Panthers Wow I'm not used to this much
agency my marvel of it and the heroes
are so enjoy this movie with great
acting
a great story great things and great
cultural significance that almost let
you forget the underdeveloped love
stories you can we mother the terrible
eat it seems good or the big forgettable
third ecru ha ha ha
I like that better neck in other words
it's a Marvel movie story Touhou
superhero formerly known as Prince Wow
there's Wallis Lupita you're so fine
you're so fine you blow my mind Lupita
Lupita here the shaving head bill Danton
token token white guys joke the best
Disney Princess wardog wave the samurai
[Music]
Arsenio Hall Show the heuristic and it
was hard to the right place but maybe
don't let every drawers keep any guys
with one arm in custody
got any line from Infinity Ward that you
haven't said yet the only thing of
butter their fears a sphere itself
Stannis and Darkseid are stepbrothers
and every beholder thinks it is the
epitome of the
kind and the only thing it fears is that
it might be wrong no no really well done
really well done stuff another one of
those honest trailers where you have to
nitpick because there's not really major
flaws you can really harp on with this
movie just point out all the things
about it in a comedic way I felt like a
lot of this honest trailer was actually
dedicated to a lot of what led up to
this movie the context outside of the
film itself you know MCU film contrast
between this and the 17 films that came
yeah yeah yeah I thought that was kind
of neat to kind of focus on that like
the first half of this honest trailer
well that whole quip about it's taking
like 18 movies to get and then it kind
of narrows it down to just a couple in
the end yeah I think there's like more
than just one moment that shows era kill
mongers essentially a bad guy I mean
when he shoots his girlfriend he does
enough bad guy things I love that line
about Andy Serkis not playing a guy in a
mocha yeah like that was the whole big
deal was he wasn't into mocap suit I
still wish they kept them around in some
way although it's a good plot point for
the movie yeah I gave it weight I loved
claw toe the main thing they really
pointed out to me that I never noticed
was Nakia and Howard Howard an entire
diamond how old she was right the entire
time that's that's one of my favorite
honest trailers things was like the
jokes are fun and the nitpicks are all
fun and everything but that was
something when I was watching oh yeah
that's great
solid point actually Nadya was right the
entire time they never did give her the
credit she deserved come on man wake up
people and they pointed out a couple
reasonable flaws about like the
undercooked love stories and stuff and I
can see why you might argue that some of
the bloat in the final fight isn't all
that memorable but those are very small
nitpicks in comparison to what this
movie is and what it means yeah all the
things I was able to accomplish aside
from that sometimes you get to these
finales and the Marvel films you're like
oh yeah they're doing the checklist of
what you got to do yeah the big fight
that's right I still felt there was a
high level of intensity both times I've
seen this film and I really enjoyed it
yeah also they talked about the co a
and I point out I thought they had a
hundred about relationship but I did a
reaction to the deleted scene of jte
from screen junkies actually I thought
that if they did have that scene it
would have made their whole love story a
lot more fleshed out and probably a lot
less complaint about that under
development it just didn't fit with the
movie at the time well yeah and they've
dropped a number of Billy to the scenes
now and I get the sense that there was
probably just a lot that they couldn't
fit into this so I wonder if somebody no
yeah totally fully realized characters
all around yeah and so that makes me
just wonder how many things there are to
complain about that maybe just got cut
down ya know they were there before
totally totally this stuff about Everett
Ross with the one arm bill and getting
capture I didn't even think about that
either the last time we saw him he had a
one hour bill that just got away and it
slipped under his fingers again he's
just a regular guy yeah and then we can
move to and they called Cherie a Disney
princess is she gonna be considered
officially a part of that I guess I
thought it could just be a joke about
Disney and Marvel I don't know is that
like there's a wiggle room for that dude
well they allow that that would be cool
I don't know truthfully but I mean I get
it she is in a sense a princess in the
Disney umbrella so technically I would
argue that she would count and I mean
what a badass princess yeah be a badass
it's not such an obvious princess - it's
like you kind of have to check yourself
beginning of oh yeah she's a princess
yeah come on I love the ribbing about
vibranium being just the magic anything
that it's fake so we can just do it
everywhere yeah whenever the plot
requires at the times let it happen and
I guess the last thing too is about how
to challahwood equip I don't think I
never quite noticed myself actually you
know she's shown restraint that's a
kingly way to be here's more the more
serious character yeah it's very kingly
and regal and yeah he's not just gonna
lay down a punchline there's moments of
humor that he has there definitely parts
where he makes you laugh but he doesn't
have the quippy dialogue like all the
other Marvel heroes it might have been a
specific choice to to help him stand out
just a little bit more yeah not quip
Woodley do certain amount of
not now after a while if just every
characters got the juice yeah when they
all get together you also need to have
foils you can't just have everybody be
the cocky right right solo type well
that was fun that was a fun honest
trailer thank you guys for doing this
man good job John Bailey good shopping
the voice the riders on astray that's
good job guys hey you guys can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification about that you notify one
of our vids is up and you can check us
out on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A s music videos a
whole bunch of goodies over there love
to have you become a patron ejected I